hello and welcome back to bloodline the
taxonomy of fear where we examine what
if anything makes a movie scary today
we're looking at the sub-genre of horror
called child gang or which we weren't
really sure was a thing it turns out
there's enough of them out there that it
is a thing yeah so we look at the movie
come out and play which is about Beth
and Francis a young couple who go on
vacation in Mexico and they they're on a
little island and they realize that
there aren't too many adults around just
a smattering of children yeah they soon
realize that something is severely amiss
and they have to fight for their lives
at the end and Beth by the way is
unreasonably pregnant given the travel
circumstance that was their first
mistake oh so what classifies a child
gang horror movie for us Jay all right
number one an intimidating number of
children the legal definition of a gang
is three or more so that seems really
small custom e3 obnoxious kids it's a
bad day in a movie yeah that's nice cute
movie yeah exactly so we're thinking
maybe like eight or nine enough to
overpower an able-bodied adult but the
problem with the kids in this movie yeah
is that yeah there were a lot of them
but they just seemed really nice and
sweet like they were play-acting and
being evil yeah it's like the director
went up to them and said hey do you want
to be in my movie and they were like
sure there's nothing else to do on this
tiny island why not yeah I wasn't quite
sold on the nefariousness and number two
it tends to be a couple that is young
and may be childless or new to parenting
and so there's an element when they're
confronted by this little swarm of
children it's sort of view overwhelming
sense of you know this is an unfamiliar
space to me I don't really know how to
confront these kids on a regular day let
alone when they're kind of looking to
tear me apart from the inside out and
Beth and Francis did seem like new
parents like we said she's pregnant
right yeah they did mention that they
had a couple kids at home and I was kind
of wondering why didn't they bring these
kids on vacation hmm there were a lot of
unanswered questions yeah and finally
the third criteria is to kill or not to
kill the children the major conflict in
these movies is
the physical conflict between the adults
and the kids it's the internal conflict
within the adults as to where do you
draw the line protecting yourself yes
only a sociopath would not pause the
idea of killing a child but then there's
a point you're like screw it these are
not children they are demon spawn
they're alien invaders I'm looking out
for numero uno yeah there has to be a
point where self-preservation mode kicks
in and you've just gotta you just gotta
run and gun all right hours of sleep
lost Jordan how many I'm gonna go with
none because despite the fact that a
very pregnant woman being on a uncharted
island with scads of murders children
that is very disturbing it was all ended
in in such a satisfying way for me that
I felt like I could move forward with
peace of mind you know I did not see
their fate coming no I don't either that
was pretty says it was a great twist
ending I lost a couple hours mostly
because of the idea that these movies
are all really just about parent anxiety
everybody worries that you know our make
is gonna turn out bad it means you know
we all have those really great friends
whose kids just turned out like you told
me yeah like we're not having them over
for dinner anymore because our cat is
terrorized and our PlayStation thanks a
lot and now we come to horror movies
survival lessons Jordan what did you
learn number one bring a phrase book
because if you're gonna be going off
into uncharted realms like these guys
are intentionally it's a lot more
considerate to others I'm responsible
for yourself to have a few key phrases
in hand instead of just asking everybody
else to speak English to you like donde
esta la policia or are you that man like
that bedrock level yeah phrases number
to do not travel when you are in your
third trimester I think that there's
like this is like a legal thing doctors
is like you cannot travel when you're
about to have a baby no tsa should not
even have let her on the plane oh no
that was a terrible oversight by
everybody involved top to bottom she was
away pregnant we have to get out of
now come on the point number three you
hesitate you die how do you think John
McClane got through five diehards how do
you think Sidney Prescott got through
four screams these people took action
and don't tell me you have too hard of a
choice to me because look at Sidney
Prescott she killed her cousin her half
brother and her boyfriend by the end of
the series and I know if the series is
done yet so it was a survivor decisive
action team ampere it was entirely pain
power that's right all right what is
your inspired video pic of the week Jack
I'm gonna recommend Village of the
Damned which came out in 1960s Maddalena
charming movie about these weird kids
that show up on in this village in
England and the 1960s the special
effects are really cheesy but the kids
they cast are sufficiently creepy it's a
good movie and I'm gonna go 90s pick
1996 children of the corn for the
gathering starring a 28 year old naomi
watts and a very young if you're a fan
of glee mark salling AKA hawk Wow and i
feel like you know you get to the eighth
ninth installment of these movies like
you can find with the children of the
corn I felt like this was a rare
highlight a bit of a bit of wheat amidst
the chaff I couldn't even get past
number two it had a few good scares in
it that I would feel comfortable
recommending so that's it for this
episode of bloodline email us at
bloodline at wired com we'd love to hear
from you and as we like to say here
bloodline remember it's just a movie or
we will put you in timeout